qu'est ce qu'elle a fait une soirée où
regarder comment les telle étiquette
c'est
lé plus faire à la et justement qu'elle
a amené plus quoi il n'est plus à faire
alan
[Rires]
à lui très fort en effet mercredi
pourquoi parce que sur le coup des 15 or
il faut savoir que l'étendard qui est
hors de l'arène est tombé à sur le mât
de de la tour ronde twins or qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire que si l'étendard
commencent à se baisser ça pourrait
vouloir dire que la reine aurait
peut-être entre guillemets pas ses
larmes aegon ont
assuré vous dans les transmissions via
un hélicoptère a décollé du château de
windsor pour aller sur la côte est
hassan d'une gamme très exactement 22
229 kilomètres pour aller rejoindre dans
le norfolk s'appelle une hausse est due
aux primes de vacances qui attendait ses
châteaux est ce que quelqu'un qu'on
puisse
le sentiment qu'il a été mis en berne à
en m1000 robert donc là ce que la reine
n'avait plus à buckingham a dit à
windsor maintenant alors son mari est
mort à copenhague nous a coûté deux
mètres de sa maison celui-ci
à buckingham palace pour l'instant plus
personne le
chantier aia pourrait en cas de toux
russell ont compris qu'ils sont
victorienne les salons d'apparat et non
considéré que ri à notre dame comme
chantier et l'autre à buckingham palace
hui en effet alors les revenus à
bourg-la-reine houba
nouveau calé au musée à bourg oulala ça
ça bouffe alors la reine être devenu
zabou recevra
[Rires]
l ado quelle est la théorie 96 en rien
ce titre il a fait un truc pour son
anniversaire ou pendant lé parti donc
comme je le disais à sandringham cette
semaine à brian sur dix mille hectares
les ailes ne séjourne pas au sein même
du château lé web forme web ferme la
ferme du bois mail que ce rachat n'était
le yoko tu paies le prince philippe que
l'on voit là
c'est là qu'elle est guérie c'est quoi
ça
[Rires]
attendre dix minutes c'est quoi cette
maison de merde c'est pas une maison
délabrée liste c'est quoi ce sera très
dur à amityville la maison du diable
il faut sort la lamal variété du prince
philip connaît a fait principe est passé
de nombreuses années pourquoi philippe
citait le mari de la reine mary
absolument est pourquoi mattel là parce
que tous les murs sont couverts des
toiles du prince philippe not least il
ya les toiles d'araignée et lorsque l'on
aime étoiles de même lorsque l'on est
dans le salon et bat pour le la petite
anecdote on voit la mer voilà bordeaux
qui m'a
dit si tu vois la mer du nord
mes frères si tu vois là tu veux mais
non je vous assure que l'on peut voir la
mer mais quelle galère tu as des via des
airbus
devant rennes est la
dépression elle est en dépression le
rire et la reine elle va pas bien féroé
la tuna walla walla il s'est plongé dans
la journée dans l'univers du prince
philippe il ya un côté un peu daphné du
maurier apeuré beckham nous soutenaient
la nuit dernière je rêvais que je
retournais à mandeure je vous dit
l'écurie ducasse de faire un tout petit
peu de culture ceni rebecca
daphné du maurier que mon succès de
daphné du jour des cartes se crut alors
et que je voulais vous dire alors ouais
bah qu'ils ont pu fêter l'anniversaire
donc dit
c'est important elle est partie et pour
laquelle à ces derniers jours après sa
naissance un amant son chef cuisinier
alors que mark flanagan elle a
évidemment j'ai une sage chef pâtissier
à quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi le plat
préféré de la reine la loubière le plat
préféré d'arrêt sur les côtes d'agneau
elle adore les colzas il à eau et les
haricots verts elle déteste fait pas
fiable et de fruits de mer et de la
rochambelle merguez la cour mendes je
pense pas tout ce qu'un peu épicée je
vais les mains trop mais c'est bientôt
favoris qui lui a d'ailleurs été ça vous
dit
chinoise
cette vie donc
oui mais voilà
l'adversaire
avec de la glace à la vanille qui
faisait des vaches du château de windsor
sineva skiff on le
[Rires]
sait son gâteau satan dieu ne me suis
pas posé sur son gazon bieber décrit
comme
tant décriée elle à chaque fois mais
n'était pas tantôt minutes tu m'as pas
de gâteau que c'est le gâteau de merde
c'était ça le gâteau de la reine avec de
la glace à la vanille
vialaret d'aller comme assise amène ce
gâteau
vous invitez mission
vous pour célébrer cette époque tunisie
on
surtout des
jeunes
si les adore ça mais oui je redescends
chauny tour descend juste qu'on est en
angleterre et alors mais c'est quoi mais
c'est en angleterre on mange très mal
mais sans déconner c'est une catastrophe
terrible moi j'adore ça va bien
j'ai peur
m non j'avais un moment déjà connaissez
un chef anglais 12
h f quoi
tu viennes chiche h f
oui
la maison pourquoi j'avais des chefs qui
date de 30 mais non
c'était parce que non s'il
est tout seul il ya un pote qui
connaissait un chef anglais présenté
malawi si tu veux je peux t'envoyer
parce que je voulais me faisais une
soirée assure week-end commencé je
prenais la
sade ou le mensonge qu'est ce que vous
voyez quelle est la vraie histoire la
vraie temps c'est une chaîne vous avez
couché avec une neige
et un moment pendant les vacances j'ai
voulu me faire grimm j'ai pris un chef
anglais pendant 1 semaine sur un chef
anglais pour certains qui fait
un prénom du chef anglais mais
non mais non en fait ça parce que jamais
j'avais j'aimerais si on ya première
censure vin d honneur j'ai un ami qui
avait un petit bateau tu t'en faire
monsieur
j'avais un petit bateau c'est un gros
mais oui et biba bien passé de 3 jours
sur mon bateau donc je dis il me dit
t'as pas en chef et je tombe dans la
gamme ea ils nous envoient un chef
anglais à samatan il est grand quand
même le bal mais non mais non c'est un
petit boulevard
charest d'amis a droit d'avoir à bobo on
était de 100 bateaux et le chef il
faisait la cuisine dans le bateau est
équipé
[Applaudissements]
sur le bateau de 6,50 à des petites
foulées du
50 avec une petite chute
en mai trois jours tous dans la nuit
mais mes potes n'ont pas supporté tu
vois il faisait très mal accueillie
faisait quoi par exemple et d'appâts il
est dégueulasse un jour il nous avait un
truc une spécialité anglaise à je suis
parti laïc le réalise vos culs de
l'agglo à base de jeunesse et
salaisons de matin marché est resté chez
mon pote sur son bateau
oui parce que les monarchies plus
ajouter deux choses la première quelle
que soit la date du roi ou de la reine
on ne fait jamais le jour de son
anniversaire mais le 2 juin non
systématiquement dos et le 2 juin que
ray une grosse fête dans sa tombe le
jour du jubilé c'est les pires car c'est
le cas
pourquoi la reine
fais pas ta belle place était donc en
version officielle puisque vous venez
non rien est-ce que c'est pourquoi la
reine et bien windsor parce que l
appelle instamment à buckingham tous les
jours ils sont en train de répéter les
funérailles de la reine comment ça se
passera à 14 ans passera alors c'est un
peu dur dur et les rideaux et pas là il
devra les répétitions bon d'accord je te
jure que c'est vrai ou faux messies
planque ses frais ou des
choses
[Applaudissements]
ça tient du 27 mars que tannis cyber
intéresse alors non merci
ils font pareil chez daniel avec
le réveil le matin y'a des gars avec des
certain
daniel nous a quittés à ma mère est née
là
c'est quand même pas ton p'tit déj
maintiennent hors de moi c'est de
jubiler les caméras du monde entier sont
fixés sur londres c'est incroyable
jamais une manifestation d'une telle
ampleur n'était organisé tu penses que
eux n'ont que ça à faire répéter les
obsèques de at
il lancé c'est bizarre quand même pu
prendre un peu moins en belgique
l'instant je t'assure qu'ils sont en
train de répéter le jubilé il faut pas
trop échauffés peut-être préciser aussi
s'est il ya quelque chose qui nous est
racontée qui est intéressant elle part
avec angela qui dit la reine elle n'est
pas parfaite je l'accepté ce qui fait
mal celle à qui dit elle a été engagée
je me dis que j'en vois là comme étant
une habilleuse de la haine et au fil du
temps elle est devenue la première de
ses conseillères on dit qu'elle est
désormais la seule sa meilleure amie
j'ai pas entendu la voix
est donc
devenue sa meilleure amie c'est al amal
accueil salle à 7,64 angela tu as well
as une botte de trop tout 80 saison
elle est très tôt et commencer la seule
à croire m et de tenues de folie jours
maintenant plus de 6000 robe elle en
juin 6000 rob dobson et c'est la seule à
connaître la combinaison du fameux
coffre qui rend qui tient au fait qu'ils
renferment la collection la plus
prestigieuse de joyeux noël 28 morts le
12 mai un livre incroyable parce que la
reine s'est livrée angela quelque chose
qu'elle n'avait jamais fait au préalable
et le deal est on et voilà on voit la
couverture du livre ah oui on attend
vraiment jazz hip hop se cogne
pour le coup ce sont les bus comme ce
livre me tarde d'y vivre
le but de ce livre là est un peu de
venir contrer le nifff paris et mégane
ça
s'ils voulaient
sortir une biographie duras a crispé
toulon c'est très bien qu'apparemment le
prince harry va fa et corinne et
fortement l'image de camilia non je sais
que les liens entre harry et kamya n'ont
jamais été très très bon et on voit la
moitié d'un événement être insultés par
bertrand mais ça c'est clair que
lorsqu'elle s'habille la reine oui on
met des petits plombs
attends attends toi à moi je serai pas
là il ya quelqu'un qui essaye ses
chaussures pendant plusieurs semaines
pour qu'elle n'ait jamais mal aux pieds
avec le cuir de la chaussure soit faite
entièrement un mec qui me soutiennent
dans la shdm absolument qui fera marcher
pendant des heures
tu peux venir
le gars me colle au sort en mode eco
masse là que tu fais dans la vie
j'essaie des choses où la reine
est pourquoi les robes sont pénibles on
ne sait pas ce que on a une reprise
aperçu balles et les jambes les cuisses
plus exactement de la reine a été voilà
très dérangé avec cela ah oui depuis
magella qu'il ya eu enfin céder les
bobos image bon oui bobo était
l'habilleuse précédente qui
hakkapeliitta b d'aller à gênés en effet
de cours élevés de plomb nous a plombé
les ourlets dérobe à onex jamais croyez
moi même si elle est en dessous d'un
hélicoptère la robe de ses rêves et ses
couleurs ont souvent aussi une
signification lorsqu'il est en vert
pomme c'était pour dire qu'elle était
pour l'écologie
un jour ils auront jean thellend je veux
dire quoi quelle est l émoi jeudi
dernier le cocu
[Rires]
tu vois rien et oise a
toujours transparent syrie pour que l'on
puisse voir la scène de partout des
quatre côtés ah ouais c'est important ça
oui au sujet du parapluie transparent
bah oui partout
pour les enfants la journée des parents
cependant se passer de laquelle ils ont
été étudié pour résister à des vents
très très fort ah ouais sinon elle est
très élégant ça risque bonne n'existe
pas des bandes castaldi c'est vrai que
bertrand n'oublie pas complètement et au
tap a demandé il est pas venu pour sera
jugé en mai et que mathieu a raison sur
ces infos la reine elle est en fauteuil
roulant actuellement les livres publiés
une seule photo et quelques cheveux
anniversaire et déjà d'un mois avec ces
deux poneys les arc bouté sur les deux
poneys regardez
pas du shaker mauricio terol voire deux
chroniqueurs
cm et on sait à l'air sympa alema
portant tyrrell a l'air fatigué
qu'on la voit sortir de sa voiture à la
battant la 96ème photo qui date d'un
mois ne peut même plus tenir debout ils
ont mis très longtemps à faire la photo
bertrand mathieu a raison elle va très
mal la haine c'est brel
prendre l hélicoptère selon vous pour
aller
on a vu des feux
allumés dans le parc le mail à 96 ans à
jamais dit qu'elle était en pleine forme
à je vous dis juste qu'elle n'est pas
mourant tenant si tu la trouves mon
grand tu vois moi je trouve pas moins
non mais t'as juteux médecin obtient
trouve pas
normal qu'à trois saisons se déplace en
fauteuil roulant possible si elle va pas
faire un footing quoi tu vois bien sûr
16 ans a pas que dans l'arène en train
d'arriver on n'est pas en fauteuil
roulant la fameuse messe en hommage au
prince philippe est lancée par une porte
latérale une autre épée mais
en foot on va prouver j'ai
été triste abs non c'est que ça tiens ça
tiens ça tient et quand tout d'un coup
ça commence à chuter va lâcher ça va
très vite c'est chute fortement il te
plait elle a chuté elle est rentrés
effectivement par une porte dérobée
derrière pour qu'on ne la voit pas mais
niasse en fauteuil roulant nature
elle n'a pas me lancer
[Applaudissements]
à
d'accord
contré mais bertrand dandini de tir il a
vraiment posé une question maîtrise très
bien belle parraineront oui pardon je me
demande à quoi tu sers
[Applaudissements]
des cas traités dits oui mais il pense
que ces infos dans la presse belge il
ferait me dire la presse en gare
mais pas avec amour il parle pas avec
comme j'aime bien sa passion pour la
reine après il sera aussi j'ai une
passion pour l'art il
ya toujours de la
centrale ou bien sûr